hello there today we're looking at
bootstrap your own latent a new approach
to self supervised learning by
researchers of deep mind and imperial
college so not almost no day goes by
where we don't hear some sort of new
self supervised algorithm right here
this paper on a high level tries to get
rid of the necessary negative samples
when doing the contrastive loss for self
supervised learning and they basically
combined momentum contrast and seem
clear and then remove the negative
samples and that seems to work pretty
well even though it's magic so yeah if
you if you want to see how it's done
stick around
share the video out if you want other
people to see how it's done and leave a
comment this this one I really don't get
what's going on so if you have ideas put
them there I'll I'll read them through
it'll be fun alright so they say we
introduced bootstrap your own latent or
be all a new approach to self supervised
image representation learning
ok so image representation learning is
the simple task of taking an image and
then feeding it through a function which
is usually like a neural network let's
let's just say this is a neural network
and in fact all of these the community
has sort of standardized this to be most
of the time it's something like a ResNet
50 ok
so what you want to do is you want to
train a neural network like a ResNet 50
to give you a good representation of the
image so this would be like H and H is a
vector and H is a representation of this
image and the representation should be
such that you can then take this
representation and solve many tasks with
it which either can be like linear you
can put a linear classifier on top of
the H or you can fine-tune the entire
architecture to solve some other task
the idea is if you have a large data set
you may use this dataset to train these
good representations of these images and
then you can transfer learn transfer
this to a task where you might be not
have as much data and because you don't
have as much data it's not enough to
completely train an architecture like
this but it is enough to take an
architecture that's been trained with
the large data set and just adapt it to
your small data set and that usually it
tends to work pretty well this is called
transfer learning this step here is
called fine-tuning sometimes and it's
sort of the approach that comes from
natural language processing from these
big transformers like Bert where you
first train on a really big data set
that might not be the data set that you
want in the end but it's really big so
you can sort of learn a lot of things
from that data set and then the only
thing left to do is to fine tune it to
basically adapt it to the nuances of
your data set but it will have learned
most things already and that's called
representation learning so the goal is
to learn a good representation now this
self supervise here is also important
because representation learning can be
as easy as if this here is image net the
image net data set contains like a
million images all with labels you can
simply train your ResNet 50 to predict
the class this is the this is called
supervised pre training or supervised
representation learning and that works
pretty well but you need a labelled data
set in self supervised learning you do
not need labels what you do is you do
self supervision and self supervision it
has many there are there many ways to do
self supervision but what we'll see in
this particular paper is that you will
take an image and you'll make a
different variance of that same image so
you'll take the image and you'll make
many many variants of it well let's just
say two so you have some procedure to
sort of change the picture a little bit
but
it's essentially still the same and you
do that through data augmentation so
this could be a random crop or you color
jitter or you rotate it or something
like this and then you exploit the fact
that you know that these two things they
should be still sort of the same image
so once you send them through your
through your encoder the representations
of the two images they should be fairly
close now let's actually read on right
here Buhl relies on two neural networks
referred to as online and target
networks that interact and learn from
each other from an augmented view of an
image we trained the online network to
predict the target representation of the
same image under a different dog mented
view okay that's sort of what we saw so
we have we have the same image under a
different dog mented view so what does
it mean what what I just said you make
two versions of the same image one that
are slightly different and then their
representation should be close now until
this point we have always thought that
this would degenerate because what if
you think of this neural network that
does this encoding to the hidden space
this ResNet 50 right here if it wants to
if you simply want to make the two
representations close what's the best
thing it can do you can simply map all
the hidden it can simply have the
constant function H equals 0 or
something like this just a constant
function because then this loss here is
always going to be 0 like perfect okay
so no matter what image comes in if you
always map it to the same thing you will
always be close in representation space
and therefore you always win that
doesn't learn a really good
representation right so what people have
done is they have included so-called
negative samples where you'll say I'll
take a different image from you know
from this
dataset but it's a different image than
this image and I also do some maybe some
data augmentation with that image and
then I send this through the same
encoder to also give me an H so this is
the H let's call that H original this is
H plus because it's the same image but
slightly differently augmented and this
is H minus which is a different image
and now the task is let's make those two
very similar to each other but let's
distance them from this other one so we
want we want this to be as far away as
possible and these two to be close to
each other now the network can't simply
map everything to a constant function
anymore right it needs to actually do
something to make these be close
together and this be far apart and the
combination of this together with the
augmentation procedure that goes into
augmenting the images has been sort of a
good combo to learn good representations
and a lot of papers have alluded to the
fact that this is so the negative
samples are to do not have these
degeneracy right so to not have the
simple solutions but the fact that the
representation then is actually good
like is good for image class image tasks
down the line probably comes from the
fact of these augmentations right here
and there's a lot of evidence of from
the fact that depending on which
augmentations we choose these
representations are going to be better
or worse for example random cropping of
an image so the random sub like taking a
random crop from the image tends to be
very very beneficial because so here
this is the same image twice right let's
say we take a random crop here and one
up here it's sort of maybe there's an
overlap here in the middle right so it
sort of needs to understand that
these random crops sir sort of needs to
communicate between these two places in
these random crops so the representation
has to somehow make sure that the object
that is overlapping here is somehow
represented but it can't represent it
just as a pixel value because it doesn't
know where the crops come from so
there's a lot of evidence that these
representations are the thing that's
responsible for making the
representations so good okay now this
paper simply says do we really need
these negative samples right here let's
just get rid of them and with a couple
of tricks this seems to work in here
this is this is what seems like magic to
me because as we go forward
think of it nothing nothing keeps this
model right here from doing the
degenerate solution h equals constant
nothing right now for some reason it
doesn't do that and I have the feeling
that this is a super delicate balance
that you have to do because when you
train when you start out it's probably
not the constant function right it's
probably some some distribution and then
simply by the fact that you train it and
kind of keep it in the so this is
certainly an optimal solution but you
might be like in some sort of local
minimum once you start training and you
simply don't get out of it during
training and that's why the network has
an easier time step by step as it
updates itself in very small incremental
steps it has an easier time actually
going for the good representation then
it has to see this solution right here
and converge to that but yeah it seems
delicate so what are they doing they are
taking that idea of taking an input
image right here and so by the way why
is it important that there are no
negative samples because
now the question is always or where do
you get these negative samples from
right should they be uniformly sampled
should we keep a buffer should we order
them there is this task of hard negative
mining where you say Oh any old negative
won't do it's actually better if we take
negatives that are you know just hard
enough there is a curricular curriculum
learning problems and so on so it would
be best to actually just get rid of
these negative things so that's why we
want to get rid of them so that's the
approach byl bootstrap your own latent
there is the input image we take one
image at a time and you apply two
different random augmentations to it
right so you create two slightly
different variants of that image through
augmentation and again this can be
something like a random crop it can be a
horizontal flip randomly you color
jitter you Solarize you blur and so on
there are all these variants of data
augmentation and the fact that down the
line that the representation of these
two things has to be close to each other
I think these random these augmentations
here are responsible what the to make
the to make the these augmentations are
responsible to make the representations
powerful okay the fact that later down
the line the network has to sort of
learn to ignore these it has to learn
that oh you know it doesn't matter where
in the image this object is because it's
been random cropped for different you
know at different locations it doesn't
matter where in the image this object is
I simply need to have my hidden
representation have this particular
object in the image and that's what
makes it powerful
okay I've said that enough now then you
have these two slightly different
versions and then you map it through
your encoder okay let's go the top path
first you see the bottom path has the
same encoder but the parameters are
different and this is going to be one of
the crucial
elements right here so this here are
your actual parameters that you learn
and this here are what are called the
target parameters now after each and you
can see this for all of these components
right here so what happens is that the
target parameters are basically a copy
of these what's what are called the
online parameters okay so after each
step you copy over from the online
parameters you copy over to the target
parameters you never learn the target
parameters you simply copy them after
each step now you don't copy them
outright what you do is you do an
exponential moving average so the target
parameters are always going to be sort
of a lagging average of your online
parameters and that idea comes from the
momentum contrast principle where the
reasoning sort of behind it is that you
need a kind of a stable you kind of need
a stable representation as a target but
I think it hasn't been fully explored or
explained why exactly that is so helpful
but we just know that if if we have the
target to be not the same as the the
online parameters but actually a kind of
a stable version of the past of the
online parameters then that tends to
work well again it's kind of the same
principle as with the augmentations with
the augmentations we have two different
versions of the same image and now with
this procedure here we sort of have two
different versions of the same neural
network but they're slightly different
right and this idea you know has been
around for much longer like the the
first Q deep Q networks and so on they
had the same principles where they had
the the network that they actually
learned and then the target network that
is copied over every such-and-such
episodes and so on so this this seems to
work seems to be a fundamental principle
that seems to work all right
so
we take our two slightly different
augmented versions of the same image and
we run them through our two slightly
different encoders to obtain two
representations now this thing right
here that's going to be our represent so
after this procedure we discard the
entire thing right here except that so
this here is your whatever your ResNet
50 okay
after that follows a projection and the
projection is is here to reduce the
dimensionality and honestly I'm actually
not sure why it is here because you can
do it without like technically the
algorithm doesn't require this
projection so you can imagine the
algorithm without the projection but
just really quickly the projection
simply brings down the representation
which is like 2048 dimensional that
comes out of the resin at 50 it has it
is a two layer neural network that first
pumps this up to like four thousand and
ninety two and then compresses it down
to 256 dimensions
okay so that's the projection Network
again there is a part that's learned and
then the target projector is simply the
exponential moving average of the online
projector but again this is why exactly
this is here probably simply because it
works right but probably because there
is no there is no distinction because
you don't have different losses you
simply back propagate through everything
and then train everything so there is no
logical distinction between the
projection and the representation other
than you have a different dimensionality
but maybe that's the point here that you
make a different dimensionality even
though you could you could do the rest
in this 2048 space yeah so for now just
this doesn't exist let's just say this
doesn't exist and we just work with this
representation here let's call this Z
z prime okay so what happens is we take
the representation and now we have one
neural network the predictor right here
that takes the representation of one of
the image versions and it simply tries
to predict the representation of the
other image version so what you want is
that Q of Z equals Z prime okay and if
we expand that is that Q of F of Z is
equal to F target of Z prime and if we
expand that even further you can see
that Q I'll just write Q and F for now Q
of F of a which is an augmentation an
augmentation of Z should be one bracket
to bracket three bracket should be F of
a of Z sorry not see that's the image X
all right so this makes a lot of sense
you're simply with Q since these are all
different here so f is the target
instead of these online parameters a is
also different it's a different
augmentation that you do but the X is
the same okay so the Q simply tries to
somehow negate this augmentation and
this difference between the target and
the online parameters but you don't tell
the queue which augmentation was used
and you don't tell the Q what are the
exact parameters of that network so what
the Q has to do is it has to somehow
it's like it's like a it has to take its
best guess right so basically the Q is
trained to output the expected value of
the representation right the expected
of the representation f of a of X under
all of the different possible image
augmentations and that's why it learns
to ignore these augmentations so your
entire goal with these methods is you
learn to ignore these augmentations so
you want to learn some method that is
independent of the augmentations so by
crafting the augmentations in a smart
way we can make these representations
contain a lot of semantic information
because what we want to do with the
augmentation is basically we want to
destroy all the non segmenting
information sorry non semantic
information and random cropping is one
of those methods horizontal flipping is
one of those methods because we say well
whether an image goes left to right or
right left most of the time the
semantics are the same the pixels are
different but the semantics are the same
so by putting an augmentation in there
we learn to ignore that augmentation
because our representation now needs to
be predictable right cuny we learn q to
predict the the representation under the
expectation of our augmentations and
that means it can't be dependent on one
particular augmentation
okay learns to ignore it so that's
basically what's happening here again
there is nothing keeping this from
simply collapsing it to a trivial
solution and it's probably a combination
of the of the initialization and the
learning procedure itself that it you
know goes on in little little steps one
by one that keeps it in the realm of
rather having to like it's easier to
learn a good representation than it is
to collapse to that to that solution
okay so again components is image then
you ought meant differently then you run
it through different encoders but the
encoders are similar in the fact that
one is the exponential moving average of
the other and then you try to predict
one from the other and that ultimately
makes the representation be independent
of the augmentation and that means that
the representation can only include
things that are not destroyed by the
augmentations and if you construct the
augmentations smartly that means you
only retain the semantic information
that's it so the loss function is pretty
simple as you can see right here what
you want is and this bar is a
normalization what you want is the l2
norm between the this representation be
close to the cue of that representation
so the cue simply tries to predict the
other representation and you do that for
both ways so you once stick the image in
here and try to predict the other one
and you do it vice versa so you get too
lost components each time it's a
symmetric loss okay and that's it that's
the method and they beat all the other
self supervised methods and they get
pretty close to the supervised
supervised representation learning
method as you can see right here as the
number of parameters goes up in their
model so one of them is resonate 50 but
I'm gonna guess this one right here but
you can also get to higher architectures
and then it appears to work even better
and come even closer to this supervised
baseline this could be because you know
if you have more parameters technically
in a supervised method you would also
need more labeled images maybe and
therefore it doesn't scale as well I
don't I don't know there is a lot of
unclarity in this research like all they
show is that their numbers are good
which is cool right and it's cool that
you don't need your you don't need the
negative samples anymore and it actually
doesn't collapse when you do that kind
of stuff but there's a lot of I don't
know there's a lot of things here for
example
we use a batch size of 4096 split over
512 TP uv3 course with this setup
training takes approximately 8 hours for
resin at 50 so they train eight hours on
512 TP use just imagine that so that's
sort of crazy amount of computation
again going into these models and then
the second thing here is that you can
see that there are some things missing
right here and there are these all these
annotations which probably means that
they take these numbers from those
papers now they allude to to the fact
that they try to follow their protocol
as closely as possible but I mean that's
never that's never given or almost never
unless they release like the exact code
and even then there are still going to
be differences in even like you'd have
to replicate the exact thing on the
exact same number of TPU cores and
whatnot so I I highly like these numbers
seem to be I'm not sure especially if
you then go and look and at some point
they actually do reproduce the same
clear baseline so you can see right here
that they have a own implementation of
sim clear and they actually compare this
to the numbers that they find in the
same clear paper and you can see for
example here there's like four
percentage points that the the their
implementation of seeing clear gains
above this implementation and if you
look at this supervised baseline that's
also from that paper and there is a
graph further down where they also
implement their own version of the their
own version of the supervised baseline I
forget here so you can see that between
the supervised in that paper and the
supervised of them sometimes there's
like a giant
gap right here for the same model it
seems so all of these numbers um I'm not
sure you should put too much weight on
the fact that this is now outperforming
the other methods I would not put like
unless this is like SuperDuper
replicated very often I would not put a
lot of weight on the fact that it is
better what I would put a lot of weight
on is the fact that it works at all and
and achieves you know good performance
and there is more they make they have
like experiments right here that show
that their method they be a B y ou L is
much more resistant to like changes in
hyper parameters so here you can see
that it falls off much later when you
reduce the batch size which makes sense
right because seem clear is one of these
methods that uses negative samples and
for negative samples it uses the other
samples in the mini batch now if you
have less samples in the mini batch that
means you have a less representative
distribution of your entire data set as
negative samples and therefore if you
increase as decrease the mini batch then
this drops off and also they show that
for example their method is much more
robust to the removal of a couple of
these image augmentations so all of this
I find actually pretty cool but the the
actual numbers here first I'm not super
duper interested that they get like two
or one points more in something but they
do perform like a lot of experiments and
that it shows that you can apply the
method to different things it's not only
like in one setting so that's pretty
cool it works at least at the you can
say it works at least as well as other
methods and it is a lot easier because
you don't have this negative sample
things now the last quarrel I have with
the paper and where is it where is it
somewhere they say that we release the
code that they release the pseudocode
they don't release the code they release
the pseudocode in the appendix so I mean
there are reasons why you sometimes want
to release pseudocode and that's if
Liane algorithm is so high level and so
simple in its high level T and so
modular to be fleshed out that you can't
like it makes more sense but here it's
like pseudocode in Jax and and come on
is it really that competitively
advantageous to retain your code this is
it's just not reproducible with this you
know that they have like 50 billion
hacks in their code and yeah so deep
mind has this history of just not
releasing like publishing behind
paywalls and and just giving pseudocode
that has lots of mistakes in them like
the new zero pseudocode you can't even
like run it in its basic form if you
fill in the things it's it's a it's a
bit annoying in any way the method
itself seems promising for
representation learning as I said
especially because it's pretty simple it
still heavily relies on these
augmentation methods so and that's what
they say right here nevertheless
py will remind remains dependent on
existing sets of augmentations that are
specific to vision applications to
generalize beyond to other modalities it
is necessary to obtain similarly
suitable augmentations for each of them
designing such augmentations may require
significant effort and expertise there
for automating the search for these
augmentations would be an important next
step to generalize to other modalities
and I'm not sure if you can do this
automating the search for these
augmentations I guess you can do it if
you have like a supervised data set and
then you can search and then you can use
those augmentations for the unsupervised
but it seems a bit bootstrap eeeh no pun
intended right here
I think the the power of the of these
representations again comes from the
fact that we have these augmentations
carefully constructed so oh yes
the last thing broader impact statement
just read this like try to estimate the
perplexity of this broader impact
statement let's go
the presented research should be
categorized as research in the field of
unsupervised learning this work may
inspire new algorithms theoretical and
experimental investigation the algorithm
presented here can be used for many
different vision applications and a
particular use may have both positive or
negative impacts which is known as the
dual use problem besides as vision
datasets could be biased the
representation learned by Buell could be
susceptible to replicate these biases
like come up so people who advocated for
making everyone do this is this what you
wanted is this like is this a
satisfactory result for you and if you
have this as a reviewer is this okay or
not I mean let's just cross out some
words here blank that's black like field
let's just put field or machine learning
why not machine learning machine
learning this work inspire new
algorithms yes the algorithm presented
here can be used for many different
machine learning applications and the
particular use may have both men - yes
besides as datasets could be biased
representation learned by this paper
could be susceptible to replicate these
biases well there is a copy pasting that
you can apparently put into any and all
papers that you write from that one and
hey deepmind's doing it so you know
there you go okay may be a bit cynical
but I'm I like I told you this would
happen I told you and you know okay so
that was it for my comments right here
they do have like a giant ton of
experiments and I appreciate that right
they really try to show that it works in
many different situations and yeah yet
to solve why this doesn't collapse but
apparently it doesn't so try it out give
it a try and I'll see you next time bye
bye